BEEN REFERRED TO THIS COMMITTEE
THE ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT.
TWO PLEASE NOTE OUR GUIDE LINE
FOR BILLS HEARD IN THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY IS TO ALLOW
TESTIMONY FOR TWO WITNESSES. FOR
SUPPORT AND TWO WITNESSES FOR
OPPOSITION TO SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH.
I WILL ALSO CALL FOR TWEETERS
TESTIMONY THOSE NEITHER AND
SUPPORT NOR IN OPPOSITION.
WELCOME MR MCCARTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE PRESENT THAT THIS
BILL RELATES TO ADULT EDUCATION
IN CALIFORNIA SO I FELT THAT OF
COURSE IS IN THE K. TWELVE
SYSTEM AND TO OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND YEAH OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
ALMOST FACE THE DEATH PENALTY
DURING THAT THE GREAT RECESSION.
HOW WE'RE ABLE TO BRING MONEY
BACK IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
THROUGH THIS ADULT EDUCATION
BLOCK GRANT?
WHERE WE HAVE NEW METRICS TO
FOCUS ON --
THE SUCCESS OF THE STUDENTS BUT
ONE THING THAT'S LACKING IS
LOOKING AT THE IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS IN THEIR INTEGRATION
INTO.
A CALIFORNIA AYE MAINSTREAM
DOESN'T ALWAYS REFLECT THE
PROGRESS THAT THEY'RE MAKING SO
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO UPDATE
THE NEW SYSTEM WE HAVE OF THE
ADULT EDUCATION GRANT PROGRAM.
AND THAT ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY AND WITH ME AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE ADULT
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION.
GOOD MORNING DON KHAKI WITH
MCCUE CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTED THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR ADULT EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA DON'T EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION.
ARE BOTH IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETY
EIGHT I'M OUTSIDE THE AUTHOR
STATED VERY IMPORTANT BILL IN
THAT CURRENTLY UNDER THE DOLE AT
PROGRAM.
THEIR METRICS IN PLACE THAT
REALLY JUST FOCUS STRICTLY OR
SEE AND A CAREER PROGRESS WHICH
ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT FOR MANY OF OUR IMMIGRANTS
REFUGEE STUDENTS WHO MAY NOT
HAVE QUITE HAVE THE COMPETENCIES
AS OF YET I TO MEASURE AGAINST
THOSE TO SET A METRICS I'M
REALLY FEEL VERY STRONGLY WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE
THOSE OUTCOMES AND PROGRESS THAT
THEY ARE MAKING.
OUT WITH REGARD TO EDUCATION ESL --
INTEGRATION OF WHAT HAVE YOU S.
ALONG A SPECTRUM OF DIFFERENT
NEEDS ARE THE MOMENTS I AM
DEFINITELY ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED ON WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY PROACTIVELY.
AYE WITH OUR IMMIGRANT TO OUR
RIGHTS ADVOCATES ON WITH THE
CHANCELLOR OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS WELL AS DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION REALLY PLEASED TO
BE HERE IN SUPPORT AND I URGE
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING EVEN COUNTRY WHAT
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES --
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
ANY TWEETERS --
SEEING NONE GOT OF COMMITTING
MISS QUIRK SILVA YET QUESTION
[inaudible]
A SECOND.
UP BUT I ALSO WANTED TO ASK HIM --
HE THEIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR
TESTIMONY ARM ABOUT IF YOU COULD
GIVE US A NARRATIVE OF THIS
IMMIGRANT STUDENT BECAUSE I KNOW
THROUGH THE QUE.
K. TWELVE OR EVEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THERE'S DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS.
AND IN THE PAST SOME HAVE EVEN
BEEN BASED ON AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL SITE FOR ACCESS SOME OF
THEM AND COMMUNITY CENTERS SOME
ARE ACTUALLY ON THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN ESL YOU MENTION I
KNOW WAS SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE --
A CLASS THAT THEY WOULD PROBABLY
TAKE BUT WHERE SOME OTHER THINGS
BECAUSE I DON'T REALLY NOTE THAT
INFORMATION BALL R. ADULT
EDUCATION --
SITES ARE STILL ON ON ALL THOSE
LOCATIONS YOU MENTION THERE ON
K. -- TWELVE
CLOCK THAT SCHOOL SITES AT MADE
MANY TIMES SHUT DOWN K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS WITH A FOREMAN ADULT
SCHOOL WE HAVE TO RIGHT HERE IN
THE CENTRAL CITY OF SACRAMENTO
SOME COMMUNITY COLLEGES SOME.
YOU KNOW PRIVATE NONPROFIT CAN
COMMITTEE CENTERS AND YOU KNOW
THE OLD THAT IS --
BASIC SKILLS CREDIT RECOVERY FRY
SCHOOL DIPLOMA CITIZENSHIP.
AND IT DOES AND SOME PEOPLE ARE
JUST YOU KNOW.
GETTING UP TO SPEED TO
POTENTIALLY GET A CERTIFICATE
AND SO THAT'S WHERE THAT WRITTEN
THIS WAS ABOUT AS THAT.
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT ALWAYS EASY
EASY TO TO MARK SOMEONE SUCCESS
BY DID THEY GET A DEGREE TO
THEIR CERTIFICATE ARE THEY
MOVING ON IT SOME PEOPLE TAKES.
MAYBE A NUMBER A YEARS UP TO DO
THAT THEY'RE DOING THE PRE WORK
MAYBE IN ORDER TO GET INTO MORE
OF THE FORMAL PROGRAMS CORRECTED
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
SHOULDN'T.
I RECOGNIZE AND VALUE THAT IS
JUST GREAT --
YOU KNOW UPSIDE FOR CALIFORNIA
HAD THESE INDIVIDUALS
PARTICIPATING IN SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT THE METRICS HOW WE THOUGHT
FOCUS ON SUCCESS REFLECT
EVERYBODY THAT'S PARTICIPATING
IN THE ADULT EDUCATION SAYS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WILK WILL GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH
A CORPSMAN THEN WE'LL COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MEDINA PRESENT [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
ARAMBULA BLOOM [inaudible]
CHAVEZ IRWIN [inaudible]
KILEY LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA HERE [inaudible]
SANTIAGO WEBER.
BOREDOM IS ESTABLISHED SO
[inaudible]
NO.
FIRST AND SECOND.
BAKER I THINK YOU'RE JUST THAT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AYE AYE.
NOTE DO YOU KNOW THAT YOU LISTED
ALL THE FOLKS WHO BENEFIT FROM
ADULT EDUCATION EXCEPT --
ONE OR TWO COMPLIANCE I JUST
WANT TO ADD BECAUSE THAT WE DO
AND HAVE THAT FULL SNAPSHOT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
TELL OUT THERE THERE ARE ALSO
THOSE WHO ARE AND OLDER IN LIFE --
AND THEY THEY CAME THEIR ADULT
THAT PROGRAMS CAME UNDER ATTACK
NOT JUST IN THE GREAT RECESSION
BUT EVEN IN MY FIRST TERM WHERE
IT WAS YOU KNOW THIS.
THESE ARE FOLKS ARE JUST TAKING
CLASSES.
TO YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO DO
DURING DAY NOW WEAVING NOW YEAH
TOTALLY WRONG --
IN MY COMMUNITY IS ALIVE --
IMMIGRANTS A ADULT IMMIGRANTS
THEIR ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE --
AND THEY ARE THEY ARE NOT ONLY
LEARNING SKILLS BUT THEY'RE
LEARNING HOW TO BE --
WELL INTEGRATED THE COMMUNITY
AND AND IT IS FOR SOME WHO ARE
AND OLDER IN LIFE WHO ARE
FINDING WAYS HOW CAN THEY STAY
ENGAGE KEEP THEIR MINDS ACTIVE
KEEP THEMSELVES ENGAGED IN THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THE MORE.
INDEPENDENT ENGAGED OUR OUR
SENIOR COMMUNITY BE --
THE MORE THEY ARE A BENEFIT TO
US AND HAVE A HIGHER QUALITY OF
LIFE THAT ALSO COST THE STATE
LAST SO I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT
OUT THERE BECAUSE THAT IS OFTEN
A MISSY NARRATIVE FROM THE ADULT
EDUCATION.
CONVERSATION THAT HAPPENED IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS.
THOSE ARE NOT ONLY GET
INITIATIVE I CAN'T THEY'RE
GETTING SKILLS THEY'RE LEARNING
HOW TO BE REMAIN ENGAGED IN
THEIR COMMUNITY AND CONTINUE OUR
LIFE LONG LEARNING.
SO PLEASED TO SUPPORT IT SPRING
THAT PITCH OUT THERE AS WELL
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE --
LIST REGARDLESS YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CONVERSATION
AND FOR THE INPUTS AND ASK YOUR
IBM.
OF AS A FORMER.
ADULT EDUCATION TEACHERS ESL
TEACHER.
I I SAW WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT I SAW HARD WORKING --
PEOPLE.
WORK ALL DAY.
GOTO THEIR WORK AND WORK EIGHT
HOURS AND THEN AFTER WORKING
EIGHT HOURS A DAY.
COME TO SCHOOL.
EAGER EAGER TO LEARN EAGER TO BE
PART OF THE COMMUNITY IS BECAUSE
BAKER DESCRIBED SO AND I THANK
THE ARE OUT THERE. FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND AS OUR
STATE'S POPULATION CONTINUES TO
GROW.
THE PEOPLE FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS AND COUNTRIES.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
IMMIGRANTS WERE SEEKING
EDUCATION FROM THE ADULT
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
I RECEIVE AN EDUCATION AND
SERVICES THEY NEED IN ORDER TO
BECOME FULLY INTEGRATED.
AND SUCCESSFUL IN THE STATE.
IN ORDER FOR THE STATE TO FULLY
ASSESS.
IMMIGRANTS ARE TRULY INTEGRATING
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
ASSESS THE APPROPRIATE METRICS.
IS BILL IS A STEP IN ENSURING
THAT DATA CAN BE COLLECTED.
AND REPORTED ON I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE TODAY.
AND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO CONCURRENT
SENATE AMENDMENTS AND PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MEDINA I MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE LEVINE AYE LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA AYE
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WET.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
THE BILL IS OUT.
AND WE WILL BE ADJOURNED